a few days ago i could have trapped your
queen after you greedily took my b porn
i challenged you from that position so
you can prove that yasser really should
be proud of your porn grounds
okay
i'm tempted now
i'm also sending a challenge to anish
giri who
i heard is maybe playing chess right now
but
he's ignoring me so in the meantime i'll
play
uh pico pico chess from
position um wait what is this
oh
i remember this
oh no so i had this position the other
day against pico chess and i guess
bishop e4 was in this other day but it's
found now so
i guess i have to take the rook
and then somehow defend g2
maybe this move
yeah this is kind of unpleasant
just have to weather the storm
it's a weird position to play from
oh anish ended his stream oh that's kind
of sad i wanted to read the niche
because he usually doesn't stream on
twitch
that's a good move okay i'll play this
so if a niche doesn't accept my
challenge this will probably be my last
game
i have to defend my glory against pico
chess
ah anish practicing streaming on twitch
to stream seriously on youtube that's
kind of funny
unfortunately i can't really do that
wait what
oh
i'm playing a niche
okay i'm playing a niche geary sorry
pico chess
uh
draw
draw
oh we're playing rated bullet why is
anish's rating so high
da he didn't pre-move 97. i thought he
was in a premium of 97. i resign
i wanted to trick him with this uh
i just rage analysis board too
how do i rematch
wait let me rematch
that's not fair
i thought he was gonna
oh i'm playing a game
no i want to play a niche
what did i do there
wait what did i do
and i drew pico chess oh no oh
everything fell apart so quickly
i'll try and explain what just happened
um
that's so bad
fail pre-move bits
also look at look at look at what he
said
oh let's
choose some emoji crying oh i feel so
sad now
so the reason to play queen d6 here
is usually
especially people who know what they're
doing they'll pre-move knight e7
in the event that white takes
black will pre-move knight e7
and then there's this trap uh
takes takes takes
takes and
uh black is happy so that's what i
thought he was gonna go for so the
reason what to play queen dixie 6 is you
exp oh we're playing another game okay
hopefully people get the point
and now i'm white again
okay this time no giving away my queen
for free
also let's punish this opening
ah he's not playing it though
okay we have a london
i'll play this sign
wait what is
this h4 i guess
yeah why am i so slow
that's kind of laggy
but i like my position actually
or do i
i don't know if i like my position
i should be playing e4 soon
how to do this
or cure
don't hurt me
that's a oh i'm getting hurt
where's my wind
i'm really getting hurt here
okay i just resigned
oh don't adopt me
okay
i don't know why i'm playing this
i guess we'll see his prep against the
budapest so
let's play rook a6 anyway
oh this is kind of a difficult position
just blunder a pawn i don't think he did
though
this move
okay let's play d5
and open things up
okay
i'm getting some tricks
okay there's a pin
it's a little bit too slow here
oh no my pawn
okay
where's my win
no
[Music]
ah okay
oh i'm a little bit slower on my laptop
ah oh rook e8 wait what what is he
saying
rookie instead of bishop g4
duh
wins on the pin
rook e8 instead of bishop g4
oh bishop e6
bishop e6 would have just been winning
okay
okay
we have a wholesome end to this very
brief match
even though he's already offline
that was kind shout out to a niche
up and coming streamer and super
grandmaster chess player
um
i'm sure people can google him find his
youtube channel
and his twitter feed
oh he tweeted just now
oh no what did he tweet
oh no
oh no
i hope the twitter trolls don't attack
me